buonasera buonasera a tutti voi io non
sono un divulgatore scientifico sono un
imprenditore e prima di lui ero convinto
di aver fatto anche in fretta
noi costruiamo un aeroplano lo facciamo
a qualche chilometro da qui lo facciamo
come non l'aveva mai fatto nessuno prima
con dei materiali che in pochi avevano
provato ad utilizzare prima e applicando
un concetto al al processo e al prodotto
che nessuno credeva si potesse applicare
per questi aeroplani così piccoli ogni
volta che ne parlavamo ci dicevano di
lasciar perdere di non farlo che non era
sicuramente il momento giusto nel bel
mezzo della più grande crisi del
capitalismo industriale che l'occidente
abbia mai conosciuto non era proprio il
caso di mettersi a fare aeroplani con
una tecnologia innovativa in puglia di
fronte all'europa meridionale a quella
che non piace ai piani alti di bruxelles
e noi seguendo una buona regola non
abbiamo seguito nessuno di questi buoni
consigli e abbiamo avuto la fortuna di
trovare un imprenditore visionario che
si chiama vito pertosa che ci ha dato
fiducia già finanziati e adesso abbiamo
una realtà produttiva a monopoly di
fronte all'europa mediterranea nel cuore
della crisi che persiste del più grande
crisi del capitalismo occidentale
un'azienda che presenta il 27 paesi del
mondo che esporta tecnologia che esporta
innovazione bene questa introduzione mi
serve proprio per parlare di questo per
parlare di innovazione e per provare a
parlare con voi di futuro perché vedete
l'innovazione non cadde su una società
come la manna dal cielo
non esiste in natura
l'innovazione è frutto di un processo
complesso e dell'interazione complessa
di fattori e di persone
eugenio garin lo dico la professoressa
che davvero ha fatto a me personalmente
ha fatto venir voglia di riscrivermi
all'università e di riscrivere mia
filosofia
diceva che crollavano le grandi
cattedrali di idee nel passaggio dal
medioevo al rinascimento e beh noi
viviamo una società che in questo
momento è in una fase di questo tipo
rispetto a tutte le altre rivoluzioni
scientifiche che si sono succedute nella
storia la ruota nella preistoria
la rivoluzione scientifica nel seicento
la rivoluzione della macchina al vapore
alla fine del settecento e la
rivoluzione tecnologica quella che
viviamo oggi
bene quella che viviamo oggi è la
rivoluzione che più delle altre più di
ogni altra ogni altro passaggio di stato
e di epoca della storia dell'umanità
necessita di capitale umano qualificato
necessita di persone che abbiano
capacità di risolvere i problemi di
affrontarli che parlano che parlino le
lingue che abbiano visione voglia
coraggio intraprendenza bene il capitale
umano è alla base di tutte le
rivoluzioni tecnologiche moderne e
soprattutto lo sarà sempre di più alla
base di quelle post moderne perché
innovazione innovare cambiare modificare
trasformare sono processi ambiti settori
della vita delle società che possono
avere una natura processuale possono
necessitare degli anni ma possono avere
anche una natura puntuale e per questo
appunto per quelle rivoluzioni che hanno
una dimensione puntuale a me piace
citare sempre folgori fosbury è un uomo
che è un giorno a un certo punto nella
sua carriera di atleta ha deciso di fare
una cosa diversa come non l'aveva mai
fatta nessuno prima ha deciso di saltare
non più sulla pancia nel salto in alto
come facevano tutti fino a quel momento
ma ha deciso di rivoluzionare il salto
in alto e di saltare sulla schiena
ecco in quel preciso momento in
quell'istante tutto quello che c'era
prima di lui
le medaglie d'oro olimpiche i campioni
personaggi che avevano fatto la storia
di quella disciplina erano
immediatamente passati nella preistoria
erano immediatamente diventati passato
questo carattere dell'innovazione
rivoluzionario dirompente
straordinariamente capace di accendere i
cuori gli animi le passioni e qualcosa
che sta dentro di noi che sta dentro
ciascuno di noi
ed ecco perché torniamo al capitale
umano la formazione l'istruzione la
capacità di muoversi di utilizzare le
nuove tecnologie sono elementi decisivi
perché questa scintilla nasca perché
questo fuoco si accenda perché questa
voglia di cambiare di trasformare di non
fidarsi dei buoni consigli
finalmente trovi una strada trovi una
collocazione è una consacrazione
definitiva ed ultima in un processo o in
un prodotto l'italia da questo punto di
vista è tanto ricca di persone capaci
talentuose volenterose tanto povera in
questo momento di fiducia la fiducia
alla set più importante in tutte le
imprese si deve scalare il k2 devi
conquistare una fidanzata o devi
costruire l'aeroplano più tecnologico e
performante del mondo non puoi non avere
fiducia nel futuro e del futuro il
futuro è una parola che è tornata spesso
anche oggi e che ha dato il titolo al
vostro bellissimo evento solo la fiducia
nel futuro e il bisogno di futuro di una
generazione può costruire le basi per
far scattare quella scintilla che per
folgori ha significato per esempio
rivoluzionare il modo di saltare
ciascuno nella propria vita nel proprio
lavoro
nella classe in cui insegna nella
fabbrica dove dove lavora dove fa
l'imprenditore persino
oggi con gli strumenti che la
information communication technology da
ha la possibilità di diventare
innovatore e diventando innovatore
confrontarsi col mercato perché il
mercato oggi e lo sarà sempre di più in
futuro
e il giudice ultimo della qualità e
della bontà dei processi di innovazione
henry ford diceva c'è vero progresso
solo quando i vantaggi di una nuova
tecnologia sono per tutti questo è vero
l'innovazione ha senso fare innovazione
ha senso se possiamo mettere a
disposizione di tutti di una platea
sempre più larga e oggi del mondo questo
processo di innovazione
questa trasformazione se quello che noi
facciamo cambiamo modifichiamo se le
sfide che lanciamo i risultati che
otteniamo possono diventare per tutti e
oggi il giudice ultimo di questo
processo e della qualità di questo
processo è il mercato costruire
innovazione per il mercato e la strada
per l'italia per smettere di essere come
li gobbo che è talmente curvo da essere
capace solo di guardare la punta delle
proprie scarpe a chi invece alza la
testa ritrova fiducia ritrova speranza e
ritrova gioia nel lavorare nello
studiare nell'inventare nello
sperimentare nel crescere nel vivere la
società di questo abbiamo bisogno e
questo guardate è l'essenza ultima
dell'innovazione non c'è innovazione
senza fiducia non c'è innovazione senza
un pizzico di pazzia ma non c'è
innovazione senza tenacia e senza
determinazione i geni esistono in natura
ma sono pochi e coloro che riescono a
portare avanti i processi innovativi di
cui si sono fatti inventori e
sviluppatori sono sempre di meno
sono sempre di meno in un paese che non
ha più la capacità di guardare avanti
con futuro al futuro con fiducia e con
speranza
allora per questo è da questo punto di
vista
l'innovazione è il motore che fa
cambiare le società che le trasforma che
dona a ogni uomo e ogni donna un
orizzonte nuovo più grande e più ampio
più importante ai cinici ai disfattisti
ha garantiti sempre e comunque a quelli
che dicono che non si può fare che non è
una buona idea che tanto l'italia un
paese buono solo per fare le vacanze che
tanto non ce la faremo
beh io dico e vorrei che lo dicessimo
ciascuno di noi almeno chi crede
nell'innovazione
continuate pure a suonare le vostre
trombe noi continueremo a suonare le
nostre campane
grazie